so Josh aw girl The Witcher is an
amazing game but it's not over yet you
can play all over again if you yeah you
can start it from scratch
the final DLC coming is New Game+ you'll
start with all your stats and levels and
stuff you can tackle a harder difficulty
but why would you want to play the same
game again I'm not sure the only reason
I would though is to hit up some of
these quests that weren't necessarily
part of the main line that I could have
missed that I shouldn't have missed and
there are a few you look at that map and
there's like a thousand little things
you can go check out yet some are better
than others
and we'd kind of be around the office
talking like did something really sick
happen in The Witcher last night and
none of us had even seen it which brings
us to the point in this video which is
we've got our favorite quests and we're
going to share with you make sure you
have a chance to either watch our
playthroughs or go through and play for
yourself and experience so the same
feelings and stuff we had about it yeah
we're gonna throw up the full
playthrough in a separate video if
you're just kind of if you just want to
check it out and not exactly go all the
way there anyway so my sick quest was I
was actually it started in another quest
where that quest ended in a bar fight
and someone died well I got sent to jail
and there were like all these ways for
me to get out of jail but I'm pretty
sure they don't end up with me talking
to like the leader of the town he's like
you're gonna die unless you kind of do a
favor for me let's feel great so I have
to go help his son and so I go find his
son and he's like we're gonna go face
our demons in this cave and then what we
end up taking drugs like right away
and then everything's kind of really
like stumbling around there's like
flying whales and with all these like
his friends yeah and they're like unique
and really cool characters one doesn't
have a tongue but he's got so much
character
he can't talk but like you kind of delve
into their history and stuff I was like
really weird spirit trip bro journey oh
man and then at the end they're like
thanks for the help here's your gold see
you never just roughly yeah I felt like
I made all these friends and they're
like and then he's like do I want do you
want to get paid and I was like yeah
he's like well you're different
oh but now that's awesome and it was
radical and it's like such a weird kind
of a side where I you know yeah we all
conquered our demons in this
that cliffs called the Cave of dreams
and it's like you gotta check it out the
full playthrough is up nice that sounds
pretty good uh my favorite quest is one
that involves continued on the line with
the ennifer after you've sort of already
done the mainline stuff in scale ago
with her she asked for your help and she
wants to find the wreckage of a ship
that used to belong to a mage or at
least the majors on the ship and you're
not really sure why without like getting
into it the reason that I found this
quest so amazing was that it explores
relationship between geralt and yennefer
in amazing ways and it ties directly
back to a story in the book called the
last witch a story in that book called
the last wish which is also the name of
the quest and the thing about the
witcher 3 more than the other games is
that it has so many references back to
all the books and all the Texas
including like been big ways and this is
this is that but it's also a
continuation of stuff that happens in
the book which you don't really see that
often in video games so I thought that
was really awesome but I thought was a
really good quest to check out if you
want to go deep into the character
school yeah I kind of got to add to the
story mm-hmm
so Rob Hanley has a favorite quest I
know what it is but you know we asked
him anyways my favorite quest was a
quest called possession and it was over
in the Skellig islands so what happened
was there was Sarris who was cross
daughter she needed my assistance in
helping her remove a curse from one of
her buddies it's a aural I could either
choose a path of either just fighting
the possession or doing some kind of
mischievous trickery so like a month to
possess them yeah some kind of monster
possess him and I chose a path of
tricking
in tricking there became the others
there is the split-second decision and
it was the most insane split-second
decision I've ever had in the game where
I literally shouted like oh my god the
decision that I did was so horrible you
know I started like fast thinking thing
like oh my god did I just like changed
the course of this game because it was
so bad like am I now this awful person
yeah there's no way to like tell if that
was the wrong decision when you're
making it right and it you know it ended
up being all right
but there was this moment where like I
was really freaking out and it was great
and I've never had that response to a
quest yes I mean if you were if you're
gonna new game+ this thing and like
didn't want to just do the same quest
you've already seen definitely take the
time to check these ones out and if
you've got some cool quests that like we
haven't heard of because I bet there's
plenty make sure you guys know Jake if
you have a plan you must what I draw him
into the space there to trade places